"Hold on a second, hold on!"
"You haven't heard anything yet!"
"Hold on a second, I'll tell you!"
This moment at "The Jazz Singer" in 1928 led to great applause in cinemas.
The first moment of dialogue started a boom in the film industry.
Improved sales from 1928 to 1929
despite the start of the Great Depression.
Warner Bros. profits increased from $ 2 million to $ 14 million a year
when these talkies got to millions of people.
For the first few years, however, they contained mostly musicals.
Speaking added a layer of reality that was missing in the movies
and enabled greater character and plot development.
Innovations in the radio and television industry have paved the way for films more focused on dialogue.
The film "12 Angry Men" has a dialogue written so well that you can enjoy the whole movie with your eyes closed.
"Talk and talk and talk, even if it's an open and closed case like this one.
I mean, have you ever heard so much bullshit about anything? "
- "I think they're entitled to it."
It has the intensity and pace that a silent film could not achieve.
I want to talk about dialogue and see how dialogue can improve the story while seeing its limitations.
Probably the biggest and immediate advantage of dialogue is its so damned effect.
- "How are you, Captain Whitney?"
- "Okay, thank you Mrs. Mallory."
- "What are you doing in Arizona?"
- "I'll join Richard in Longsbury. He's there with his troops."
- "She is much closer to Mrs. Mallory. He was transferred to Dry Forku."
- "That's another stagecoach stop! You'll be with your husband in a few hours."
From a ten-second dialogue we know who Lucy is,
where is it, where will it go, why is there, what does her husband do, where is her husband,
where is the next stagecoach stop and how long it will take for the couple to be together again.
The dialogue is quick and simple.
But the interpretation of the dialogue can bore the viewer.
Like when we have to listen to the main villain monologue who explains the diabolical plan through the computer.
I think voice-over is a lazy substitute for a strong and effective dialogue.
Although sometimes there is no other way to do it.
There is a good and bad option how to interpret the dialogue.
Let's say that the characters' parents die.
It should tell us this:
- "O, what would Mom and Dad say?"
- "I don't know,"
"they are no longer with us,"
"they died when I was 3 years old, remember?"
Or like this:
- "Leave Billy."
- "Mom would let me."
Interpretation should be descriptive and not entirely simple.
There's a difference between saying something and revealing something.
I call it the "Dead Parents Test" for dialogue
because many movies have a problem telling us that parents will never be here again.
- "My mother's name was Susan" She was killed in a car accident with my father and they're both dead, "
"stop trying to bring them back!"
The dialogue should reveal that the character is no longer part of the frame than to shout.
It doesn't always have to be through dialogue.
And it can even be funny:
- "And for every Valentine's day, he inexplicably sends me a cactus."
"And I do, 'Thanks to the pile of ugly coyotes,"
"These cactuses are worse than your abandonment."
But it will tell us something instead of telling us.
It goes through the "Test of Dead Parents" unless it's completely dry.
Because, frankly, it's just lazy.
- "And with the number of lifeboats times the capacity you mentioned,"
"forgive me," but "
"Looks like there's not enough for everyone on board."
I think the same idea applies to the dialogue that examines the main idea of ​​the film.
"Interstellar" is a stunning movie, but this dialogue is conceived and set very hard.
- "Love is the only thing beyond the dimensions of time and space."
"We should trust her,"
"even if we can't understand her yet."
Perhaps it is better to have a theme hidden in a more ordinary dialogue.
- "And miss the Academy!"
"If I want to fly, I'll find a way to fly."
Or reveal the topic 'visually.
The dialogue always serves a story or a comedy purpose, no matter how random it looks.
In the movie "Pulp Fiction" the dialogue looks insignificant
but it sets the main points of the plot and conflict.
Vincent and Jules have a ten-minute conversation about whether or not cheating is
when a man makes a woman a foot massage
- "Look, I made a million women a million foot massages and they all meant something."
"We look like nothing happens, but happening"
"that's why it's so popular."
"There's something exciting about not talking about,"
"but you know it and she too,"
"and Marsellus knew that too."
"and Antwan was supposed to fucking know better."
This conversation - very informal to the surface
it strengthens the fact that Marsellus Wallac is not to be fooled.
When Vincent spent his night with Mrs. Wallace, an earlier interview reminds us that there is a lot at stake.
And Vincent may or may not cross his boundaries.
- "So you go there, say good night,"
"I had a very nice evening,"
"you go out the door, get in the car,"
"You go home, you make it and that's all you do."
Tarantino uses a dialogue to point to character errors.
Jules and Vincent get a big cup of coffee and praise him to be decent to Jimmy.
But that only makes Jimmy angry because Jules and Vincent don't focus on the problem they've done.
- "Do you know what's bothering me now?"
"It's not my coffee in my kitchen."
"It's a dead nigger in my garage."
Their thankful, courteous and charming dialogue failed them
but Winston Wolf, he knows a good way to react because he's Wolf.
Tarantino's dialogues are masterfully layered.
He seems to be talking about nothing, but in fact the dialogue outlines the main conflicts
in the rest of the film.
- "You shot me in a dream, you should wake up and apologize!"
Do not listen to those who say that dialogue is bad and visual expression is better for the film.
It's not true.
The dialogue is wonderful, revealing and hilarious.
It's just good to know when to use it.
- "Yeah!"
- "I'm a walrus!"
- "It's out--"
"Shut up, Donna!"
"VI Lenin. Vladamir Ilyich Ulyanov!"
- "What the fuck is he talking about?"
If you liked this topic, you should have a look at the Channel Criswell's video.
He only talks about the same subject in more depth than I do.
Also a big thank you to all who supported me on the Patreon site and follow me on my crazy Twitter
@ SwagThuf4Lyfe
Thanks for watching. Subtitles: Martin Wetter
Subtitles: Martin Wetter